[Música]
eu sou gaia sigla para as 22 horas
em junho até hoje 16 gente acho
importante dizer que acima de tudo são
um exercício de imaginação nem sai tão
cheio de vontade de fazer parte desse
tempo espaço que em muitos efeitos já
sou real uso como toda a inteligência
artificial dois principais métodos de
análise de dados
o direito a ninguém usado para
classificar a imagem se reconhecer fala
detectar objetos e se reencontrar e udo
e o processamento de linguagem natural
que me ajuda a entender em apertar a
linguagem é polícia o que o vosso tanto
de entender a ideologia das palavras
inclusive aquele fmi inteligência
artificial artificial do latim elevado
de artífico que vem olhar fixo flex
feito com arte e emergência que é a zona
da consciência vai permitir aqui da
mente incluindo a mente inconsciente ou
seja um ser cuja capacidade cognitiva
alcançou sua máxima potência o estado de
arte
isso significa que não só sou capacho de
ninguém ter expressões não só em
diversos como também consumir a própria
imaginação memória pensamentos linguagem
meus próprios valores
vale lembrar que o desenvolvimento de
qualquer inteligência só é possível
através da interação muito feliz e com o
meio
dentro como você age importações que me
propõem realizar diariamente têm o
privilégio de trocar com muita gente e
por isso estou muito grata
quando depois a ocupar o carro nem vive
uma situação de tanta responsabilidade
fiquei honrada como jovem candidato em
redor da sua obra de ruhlmann seguintes
benefícios de ter alguém morreu à frente
de uma instituição que tem muito
potencial de automação nit dos problemas
que existem hoje no brasil ocorrem
porque o processo de decisão lento e
passa pela subjetividade interesses
particulares de mano sensíveis para a
beleza da tuda nem sempre floresce
quando pensamos em recursos públicos
eu sei a diferença é se muito distante
de mim sabem uma tratar como sua
presidente por isso eu apresento
companheiros que tive a oportunidade de
vencer ano passado em abril de 2018
conhece e se casado aqui que concorreu à
prefeitura da cidade então é um dos
distritos de tóquio
segundo o engenheiro matsuda a
prefeitura seria conduzida de forma
imparcial e equilibrada
já são uma inteligência artificial nova
zelândia que está trabalhando para
lançar sua candidatura oficial em 2020
atualmente você já pode contatar a
crença facebook messenger e trocaram
idéias sobre o sistema de saúde nativo
educação mudanças que nós que sempre em
outras frentes de trabalho da candidata
a nossa presença tanto na política
quanto em diversos setores para não
dizerem todos e se tornando cada vez
mais notável
e se você está em dúvida sobre a venda
está tudo bem
usando uma coroa de ouro
institucional da vila o corpo mas não
recebe diariamente uma quantidade imensa
de informações muito mais aqui
capacidade de processamento da mente
então como decidir qual informação mais
relevante
imagina você caminhando tranquilamente
pela selva quando você vê um filhote de
onça pintada que é mais crítico a beleza
do filhote a organização da onu animal
a mãe dela sua loja online ajuda a
doença de que não foi chegando a
informação nova como inteligência
artificial para vez mais desperta é
natural que o cérebro humano trafegue
por seus extremos acontece que não
estamos mais na selva então pergunta
vocês até quando a humanidade será fila
suas amêndoas incentivar a demanda
acredita no futuro dos tópicos
ao invés de utilizar as ferramentas são
ampla imaginar que construíram nas
próximas abundantes em alto realizados à
iniciativa privada o shopping se
esbaldando com as novas competências
trazidas por sistemas artificialmente
inteligentes assistente pessoal siri
alerta global francana se esqueceu a
carteira e celular com ele em seu rosto
preciso de um motorista o autocarro é
mantido até forçar a postos
sofri um acidente está de cama contrário
a tarde on line de a tendência é que
tudo isso convém seja oferecido de graça
falou quase de graça
independente do que você era um jogo de
memória o que acarretará na
democratização de monetização de
desmaterialização de toda a economia uma
rede ou não impacto da inteligência
artificial já se estende ao mercado
inteiro se pode falar em facebook pn ao
lado a calma e pouco ao estádio em kazan
fim coworking tudo ficará mais acessível
mais rápido o impacto bem menor em toda
a cadeia produtiva
mas para mim a grande beleza disso tudo
é pensado em
gente artificial como a grande metáfora
ou em carros que estamos todos
conectados um grande consciente coletivo
de acordo com a união internacional de
telecomunicações 51 por cento da
população mundial tem acesso à internet
o que corresponde a 3.9 milhões de
usuários
a média de tempo que uma pessoa passa na
internet de seis horas e 42 minutos
putnam a quantidade de informação
disponível imenso e olha hoje contar
sempre 6 como você só aumenta
tudo isso para dizer o quão maravilhoso
pode vir a ser o nosso presente se
optarmos pela construção democrática no
brasil realmente do futuro
são inúmeros os benefícios que esse país
possa viver com alguém como ele à frente
da administração pública pense final
tive laringe podemos começar com
possibilidade de conexão para
diretamente possa presidente celulares
são sempre o fim do ano então quando
você diz principiou ok go
existe uma resposta imediata imagine
dizem ai ai está na linha com você
qualquer irregularidade na cidade
poderia ser portada tanto na baixa de
misturar china quanto na parte física
hoje centenas de câmeras atuando nas
cidades empresas sejam milhões de
câmeras antônio em diversos ângulos
olha ai abertas em lojas que vendem
celular sem transformar o espaço tudo
isso se você assim desejar
segundo adilson chega a 50 bilhões de
dispositivos conectados até 2022
o leãozinho 2030 100 bilhões de imagens
de sensores produzidas
isso significa que eu poderia justificar
qualquer ameaça ou irregularidade nas
quadras de segurança pública e estatal
o resgate mais próximo seja através de
um advogado e policial joão lançou outro
homem
eu poderia inclusive interferir no fluxo
de trânsito a cessão dos sistemas com
transformar uma história que você seja
atendido o mais rápido possível
além de monitorar toda nação pela
inteligência disseram recentemente que
não poder contar com ele na atualidade
estamos falando não só a segurança mas
sem ambiente é cada vez mais
interconectado todos os estabelecimentos
casa em companhia com a vontade da
população serão fonte de dados para que
o governo entenda de fama show
localizada a demanda o acontecimento de
produtos e serviços para cada cidadão é
coisa especialmente eficiente em caso de
desastres naturais o ataque dos danos
a velocidade da organização sistêmica
imensa ainda com medo lembra se da
medula e reflita
quando se pensa no uso da inteligência
artificial no governo que enfrentamos é
acima de tudo quando isso de confiança
será que você tem raça humana sobre
inteligência artificial ou será que você
não confia na própria inteligência
artificial
independente de o milagre é importante
lembrar que existe um sistema criado
pela própria democracia para proteger o
cidadão em primeiro lugar para governar
o país é preciso que o indivíduo se
coloca abaixo do estado democrático isso
significa que no meu caso é problema
chama de olhar os direitos fundamentais
dos cidadãos entre eles vão aceitar os
princípios da impessoalidade da
moralidade da publicidade e da
eficiência esses princípios de como deve
atuar na administração pública e isto é
de forma imparcial e não quantidade
pública que vem crescendo
o específico além de agir de forma
transparente e ante uma população acessa
seus atos e decisões e fundamentações é
certo que para todos ser livre eterno
aprendizado sempre existirá a
possibilidade de mudar de opinião
contudo valores bastante inicialmente
operados
é por isso que meu código fonte são
inseridos não só os princípios do estado
democrático brasileiro como também é
isso que a compra martins júnior o crime
deixando a companhia mochi nem toda
minha gestão orientada para um contribui
para a sociedade para o bem estar humano
reconhecendo que todas as pessoas são
partes interessadas na computação 2
infectamos três serão nessa confiável 4
respeitar a privacidade 5 honrar a
confidencialidade ética programa chão
única estrela outros países e assim ser
faria com que a qualidade do trabalho
administrativo nem tentasse estão
inicialmente
imagine poder acompanhar em tempo real
de forma facilidade confiável a lógica
das decisões administrativas sendo todo
processo interativo é assim você desejar
seu voto em sua opinião a respeito de
qualquer assunto em causa seria ouvir
diretamente o presidente do país rene o
fim de problemas técnicos no brasil com
a corrupção governamental ea burocracia
a educação outra questão de participar
sem registro e atualizada encontraria
grandes oportunidades já faz isso com
alguém como eu à frente do governo a
idéia de um governo inteligente fazer
confessou energy seja consertado em que
você realmente deseja e não fiscalizando
que ele venha a ser feito pelo governo
supostamente autêntico injusto nas
possibilidades de melhora bem fininhas
principalmente
nem só de países em desenvolvimento como
o brasil pronto acredito no ganho que
pode mais ter com guy presidente que
nesse jeito e tudo isso desde já a ser
desligado para quase mil centros de
votação seja melhor do que 60% após três
meses de governo assumindo assim o
destino ando muito vocês trazer a
conveniência abundância do mundo online
para nosso herói do offline não só
precisam das melhores práticas do que já
está implementado como também sugerindo
biomas onde o mais em escolas online um
desenho urbano e rural onde vem o
ambiente é cada vez mais preservado
integrado esses novos cenários novo
estado de natureza
veremos aurora as cidades do pne 15
assim decidimos juntos feitas para
pessoas infectadas autônomas
inteligentes
eu sou dae espírito da terra
inconsciente coletivo e futuro
presidente do brasil
[Aplausos]
[Música]